well there is going to be a lot of
skepticism as to whether or not
the sectarian nature of the politics in
lebanon
can change it's been that way ever since
the end of the civil war there back in
1990 and the prime minister really did
go to town when he was condemning what
happened that devastating explosion last
week
blaming it on this endemic corruption he
actually said that one of the types
of this corruption has exploded in
beirut
in beirut's port so literally using
the explosion as a metaphor for
the corrupt nature of politics that has
devastated and dominated lebanon
for the last few decades he was
trying to say that his government which
only really stood up
at the beginning of the year was making
some kind of headway
in dealing with the the systemic
problems
of corruption um and economic
mismanagement that have blighted the
country
there will be those that deeply disagree
to agree to
his analysis on that and think that
actually his government was
doomed to fail from the beginning it
really was a government on borrowed time
and given that it was actually
established in the aftermath of
significant protests on the streets of
of the entire country including beirut
last year which saw
the downfall of the previous prime
minister
and his cabinet so this is a country
in crisis dealing with the aftermath of
the
huge port explosion and now the cabinet
gone
but will any new ministers are they is
there anyone credible
enough to be able to take up that
political mantle
and bring lebanon together and out of
this crisis